il a remplacé au pied levé jean luc
merci avantageusement non pas du tout
vous ressembler comme deux gouttes
bâillon mais qu'est ce qu'il fait là
c'est pas partir ce qui est petit est
dans le coup vu qu'à deux secondes où
les questions j'adore les questions clés
alors vous faire plaisir
et voilà bonjour je m'appelle munich je
voudrais savoir pourquoi vous vous
arrêtez pendant les vacances
est-ce pour améliorer les missions ou
juste parce que vous êtes des grosses
feignasses
c'est une très bonne question germanique
et j'ai envie de répondre un peu des
deux cyril pour améliorer le programme
et les chroniqueurs parce que ce sont
des feignasses
merci comme nous le rappellent tous les
jours syrie dans les briefings d'avant
émission c'est lui il bosse sans doute
trop inquiets car ils commencent à
fatiguer je suis dit pas le contraire
sur la patate
non ça commence à se voir fatigué la
semaine dernière par exemple on recevait
au côté de jean claude van damme numéro
berkani d'eau ah oui mais moi je suis
basique je m'attends tout vous m'écoutez
non mais on recevait chef pana clock la
tanière jeff qu'on adore et qu'en séries
la main d'invités effet des tchèques 1
là il en a fait un jeff et un autre une
marionnette de singe qui a les bras bout
et la petite ans
ça vous fait rire bien désormais alors
et en plus c'est pas fait qu'une fois
mais je sais je pense que c'est de la
fatigue ça c'est comme de l'autre il
céda conneries ça change en direct mais
c'est comme l'autre jour dans tpm paix
ouvert à tous ouais quand vous avez fait
cette présentation
je pense que c'est votre meilleur de
l'année et voilà sauvés il m'a dit que
chez voilà c'est maintenant c'est y
vient il est chez lui à montbarla me
rappelle ma dit qu'on n'aura pas été non
voyants l'hexagone a et voilà que tu
quittes venir nous voir ma vie et en
public aussi oui de me salir ni
paillettes et par là je parle du tournoi
il ya plus de monde dans les loges ce
nouveau public
vous allez dans les loges sont écrasés
un péno direct bar mitzvah décrit les
fatiguer un donc dans ces cas là qu'est
ce qui peut recharger un être humain ou
un mot amour tout simplement et
honnêtement que quand vous dites à
quelqu'un je t'aime qu'est ce que vous
attendez un retour qu'est ce que vous
voulez entendre moi aussi
ouais ou je t'aime ou six mois là bas
c'est pour ça que si elle avait dit à
patrick timsit qui les mettrait bien une
patate meilleur sur terre
le thème très fort tu sais merci on va
pas se mentir quand tu dis est une fille
je t'aime et qui est très bon merci ou
un gentil tu es un petit coup derrière
la tête mais c'est pas grave parce que
cyril et y donne sans attendre en retour
et il est très à l'écouté
il ya quelques semaines je m'étais
gentiment moqué du quart d'heure son
flip qui durait entre trois et cinq
minutes près par résultat maintenant on
a ça
l'essence de vérité vous dit toute la
vérité les chéris vraiment pendant cinq
minutes c'est sans fil
voilà grâce à ces trous dit qu'on sait
maintenant que dans l'émission on dit la
vérité pendant cinq minutes mais ça
change tellement vite ses rubriques 1 il
faut savoir que si depuis la rentrée de
septembre il ya eu 7 142 nouvelle
séquence
c'était juste pour le plaisir de faire
des nouveaux jingles presque autour de
la table on n'a pas toujours le temps de
parler et on a le temps de chanter on
connait tous au taquet la plus attaquée
c'est une surprise c'est fini c'est
géraldine maillet elle a pas l'air comme
ça notre stagiaire de la grande
librairie est là dans les jingle alors
si vous n'avez pas encore fait votre
niche de noël ya peut-être quelque chose
à rajouter
m
moi
elle
après c'est les infos people
m
on attendait que ça circuit
2 qui m'a touché qui repartit famille
ben laden must ému de la laigne
publicitaires car installé et cinq
personnes et julie il reste du monde un
père oui et comme la musique par dj il
faut aller le chercher dans sa façon de
jouer de la musique un mariage sont sexy
vous ai pas regardé alors n'ai pas
regardé sur la tête des gosses à faire
deux choses en même temps ici parce
c'est lé tranquille bodas fait beaucoup
de peine
bon alors géré a dit qui chante du
jeanne mas et c'était bien évidemment
lors du fabuleux prime baba ok oui où
tout le monde avait donné de la voix
pour célébrer la chanson française alors
c est ce que vous saviez que pendant la
pub de ce prime
vous savez organiser un facebook live
animée par maxime un concours de chant
chroniqueur surtout un très grand moment
de télévision
car devant derrière de bois normalement
je devrais pas le diffuser ça met du
temps à autre on doit faire face à des
grandes catastrophes
oui et en tirer les enseignements pour
que plus jamais ça ce drame s'est
déroulé le lundi 4 décembre
j'adore salut salut nous sommes en
direct du facebook live de tpm père avis
vous avoir pendant cette coupure pub
pour cinq minutes de pure folie et oui
du commun et les nouvelles la musique à
fond donc je vous entends attaque mais
ce n'est pas grave on fait comme ça
c'est l'improvisation c'est de la
télévision ce l'audiovisuel on est là
pour tous
merci bravo pour vous applaudir
vous allez c'est pas franchement
annonçons qui a gagné 3 2 1 5 et 10 kg a
gagné
nouvelle session live en trois minutes
de folie on va me voir confronter notre
amusant mais chelle qui va tenter le
chanteur iggy avec qui tu as chanté jean
michel c'est pas du tout et
jamais
le dd
du cô
et
on incarne sommes désolés nous avons
posé cette prestation aussi minable et
on espère la plus prochaine sera
beaucoup mieux ans la bomba désolé on a
coupé
vous le verrez de vous même à tout à
l'heure et on essaiera d'être plus calés
pour la prochaine fois merci de votre
fidélité et a tout de suite sur le live
du tpp sur ces 8 et dire qu'il ya c'est
vrai le karine à grenade les autres
chaînes voilà tu en as pas avec
impatience ils vont dire toutes les
merdes qu'on n'a pas eu lieu on les met
en face ça va être génial
bah oui c'est bien lui revient je sais
je ne sais pas ce que vous allez voir
dehors c'est vrai que génial
enfin je pense que celui qui a pris le
plus de plaisir dans cette séquence
c'était mokhtar une séquence qui
auraient pu alimenter elle seule le top
gênante mais non dans les moments
étranges et un celui de tpm paix cette
semaine j'avais d'autres choses
m j'aimais bien
qu'ils ignorent
g
catégorie 2 points partout
ces panneaux ils ont cherché unités 5
c'est n'importe quoi
des mots pour toi
dada bon faut que je vous dise la vérité
avec ce décor de noël la c70 espèces de
mouches atanassoff away mais benjamin
herriau pas se concentrer les space et
tous les jours mais à chaque émission il
arracha man show il le met sur la tête
de chaque année il rigole tous cependant
2007 j'avais montré c'est le premier
jour j'avais été doucement le deuxième
avait pris un peu la confiance
et
il est connu pour sa méconnaissance et
j'ai besoin de vous les gens croyaient
le verra également sur les saints michel
et des moisissures la tête dans ton face
alors excusez vous je me suis je là dans
le seul bar aux doigts d'or le ciel
aimerait bien le plus fort plus haut
elle c'est juste une chose elle sait que
moi c'est ma chouchoute avis ouais c'est
comme ma soeur c'est comme ma soeur on
pourrait dormir nu et qu'ils avaient tôt
fait rien on va essayer pour voir bavent
va essayer isabelle quand vous voulez
dormir à nu tous les deux dans un lit et
du béret bas franchement je voulais
donner ce pourquoi je moi je
isabelle voilages et j'envie voit la
dette avec elle de vol à 2 je voudrais
aider
isabelle et kelly pour moi c'est pareil
à ses deux copines
ludivine par ailleurs à ce que des mères
elles seraient d'accord elle de coucher
avec vous oui laure mirny tornades est
donc vous êtes d'accord t'es d'accord
isabelle mois pour dormir milder tout le
temps lui donc ça ne pose pas de
problème mais témoignent aussi à ben oui
mais ce qui se passera rien ah oui mais
pourquoi vous voulez tous dormir nuit à
côté
vous n'êtes pas mal nu à aulas c'est des
jeux comme ce n'est pas parce que je
vous rappelle que à las vegas on vous a
vu passer traverser tout le hall de
l'hôtel doit les américains en étaient à
un ambassadeur suggestives si je puis me
permettre
la seule référence à alain aussi donc on
connaît toute la 2e vive l'habilité
genre là et avant bah quoi bien sûr
qu'est ce qu'il ya voilà et mega montée
bien sûr ça va bien honnêtement la
montée vous allez mes gars ou sauvage et
mal à isabelle isabelle ces masters
qu'elle était allée moteur du jeu en kit
et aujourd'hui elle mouafo chirac index
alors on était dans le domaine
capillaires et d'ailleurs je vais
revenir une dernière fois sur le ba-ba
hockey
car ce soir là jean michel était il vous
rappeler en quoi était déguisé
jean-michel jean-michel non car je
regarde très peu dans le fond soit
exactement était un club français avec
une perruque très particuliers risquent
elles étaient vivantes
enfin je crois parce que pour le coup
l'émission elle a beaucoup bougé ce cas
si vous regardez juif je serai prêt de
jean michel vous avez un bon résumé la
soirée au caire
pour l'instant les barques à son plus
proche de broadway on va passer à la
deuxième catégorie le surmoi
le choix va leur passer ça
il est temps de passer à tous qu'on
n'avait pas voulu voir et entame cette
semaine et on commence par jean michel
agent méfaits qui nous prouve une
nouvelle fois qu'il a beaucoup de
répartie messin bravo bébé est battu
l'encouragent
c'est pas jojo paraît alors j'ai pas
fait le lancement mais c'est parce que
en fait ils visent un foot à côté jean
michel nous a prouvé qu'elle ait
beaucoup de la partie puisque là vous
allez voir du tac au tac et rebondissait
sur une vanne d'elie semoun
qu'ils applaudissent n'importe quoi
regardez vos plats
grégoire avec nous
et
si tu as besoin de l'avis d'un
professionnel tu m'envoies avant ton doc
comme ça si on parlait quelque part au
fin je l'aurais vu ouais ouais ouais je
dirais que c'est de la merde
à
bongo
un animateur ou une animatrice
non vous gym gym
non enfin oui monsieur
c'est pour préciser notamment comme jeu
on est artiste avec mickaël isabey par
pas une capote pour nabih berry n'est
pas seulement j'en ai un
lenny panini kim aussi famille
noah intérêts civils
mais il s'est fait avoir gilbert il
avait écrit une chanson était passé dans
mon émission de radio à cause de
problèmes de c'était de livraison de
fioul te rappelles way au home a pas
livré le fuel et la belle affaire
on va voir un comédien français qui
s'appelle pierre de la danse chant qui
nous parle du complexe du petit zizi
renard
le bruit là et le chauffeur
la bouche
je note
tous
ça allait de soi
m
ces manuels à launois ces mamies elles à
la rochelle attention j'aime pas ça
bricole un peu distraite ans jean luc
lemoine